more women fighting breast cancer across
southern nevada will get the help and
support they need after our community
helped raise 77 thousand dollars in one
day as kirsten joyce shows us that's all
thanks to the caring place program and
the ladies pink tea charitable golf
tournament
nikki you're a cancer survivor of 15
years how does it make you feel to see
all these people come out and support
other survivors it's amazing it truly is
nikki rudy is part of a sisterhood that
no one asked to be a part of when
someone's diagnosed it's a tragic and a
horrible situation and many don't know
where to turn so they turn to the caring
place and when they do they get help
with food basic needs mortgage and rent
payments medication hands-on services
like massage therapy and reiki the
caring place is a program of nevada
childhood cancer foundation with
professionals assisting women and their
families every step of the way many of
the clients are now coming to us and
needing individual counseling support
and our support group so those have
grown
greatly over this time this past year
has given us so many challenges and
breast cancer is no exception for 19
years funds raised at the ping t
charitable golf tournament at southern
highlands golf club have helped women in
the fight of their lives ladies what's
the cheer
our partnership with the caring place is
something that's extremely special not
just for us but for our entire club and
our community and the hope of one day
finding a cure kirsten joyce live local
now